this year the pandemic is casting a
shadow over traditional christmas
celebrations here's an example only a
handful of people
attended the annual tree lighting
ceremony and fireworks in bethlehem
most christmas events have been shut
down with the preservation of
life-taking priority
normally thousands of tourists would
have attended mts tayab shows us now
how the city is still keeping the
christmas spirit alive
[Applause]
bathed in the shimmering winter sunlight
all the trimmings
of a holiday wonderland and while the
tree is up and the ornaments are on
the crowds are missing bethlehem's major
square is bracing itself for a christmas
like no other says father issa talgia of
the church of nativity
christmas will be a little bit sad but
we know that
maybe by praying by raising up our voice
to god
that things will change and coronavirus
will disappear
last year this is what christmas was
like in bethlehem
streets heaving with tourists and
pilgrims from around the world
soaking up the festive cheer where jesus
was born
but in march the gates to the biblical
city were slammed shut
after the israeli-occupied west bank's
first major outbreak of covet 19
erupted here according to the ministry
of health there have been over 65
thousand cases in the palestinian
territory
and more than 620 deaths resulting in
strict lockdowns that have spelled doom
for many of bethlehem's small businesses
all the people they are afraid and in
the city you feel the
spirit of the birth of jesus but
these days there's nothing we don't feel
any spirit
it's sad the eerie silence isn't just on
the streets
it's also in the churches here at the
church of the nativity
where it's believed jesus was born on
this very spot
there are no crowds no choir singing
and just the precious view of the
faithful but for carmen gatas who speaks
for bethlehem's local government
it's an opportunity to get closer to the
teachings
of christ but this year we go to the
essence of the christmas
we go inside ourselves think about the
the spirit of christmas the religious
meaning of christmas
we think and we feel with our beloved
ones
having family and friends safe is
christmas
especially in this situation it's a
really beautiful thing to say that
the spirit of christmas is keeping each
other safe
with coronavirus infections still rising
across bethlehem
midnight mass has also had to be scaled
back
merry christmas and the closest many
will get to the annual tree lighting
ceremony
will be by watching it online via a live
feed
digitally bringing light into a world
that this year
has seen so much darkness for cbs this
morning
i'm impeached